on this wednesday night tough
restrictions return to parts of quebec
what the exponential spread of the
variant is doing who is getting sick
and what needs to be done the light is
at the end of the tunnel but
the risk is so high news about a
clinical trial on children of the pfizer
biontech vaccine
what it revealed and are vaccines for
kids coming soon
tearful testimony
a man who pleaded with police as an
officer knelt on george floyd's neck
takes the stand and a pr stunt veers off
the road
at first when i heard it i was pretty
shocked how volkswagen's joke
backfired
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we approach april and more canadians
get vaccinated hope is being tempered by
what's happening
in hospitals in some parts of this
country covid19 cases are rising
driven by the more transmissible
variants and younger people are getting
sick
only two things will stop the spread
vaccines and
staying away from each other late today
quebec's premier announced tighter
restrictions are being reimposed in four
regions there
and three cities will be under lockdown
measures starting tomorrow night in
quebec city
gatineau and levy all non-essential
businesses and schools will close
and the cities will be under an 8 pm
curfew until april 12th
so everywhere in quebec we have to be
more careful
with the variant we can see an explosion
of cases
within a few days we're ready
to act quickly and strongly if the
situation worsens
in these in other regions
this is the picture across the country
today bc alberta saskatchewan and
ontario have the highest active cases
right now
those four provinces are also reporting
some of the highest rates of the new
variants
and hospitalizations are climbing too
intensive care units are filling up
there are 80 critical patients in bc now
63 in alberta and 23 in saskatchewan
and today ontario hit a new record data
from
critical care services shows 421
patients in icus
that is the highest number since the
pandemic began
the message from all public health
officers heading into the holiday
weekend
now is not the time to get together if
you gather
as usual you are taking a great
risk it is just
an invitation to covert 19 variants
to spread how many times have we heard
that over the last year
it is hard to accept but these new
variants are changing the game and they
aren't waiting for politicians to decide
what to do
abigail beeman has our top story tonight
pandemic passover easter and ramadan
round two we could go through one more
cycle
of those holidays where we forego that
getting together with people other than
those with whom we live
then not only will we keep people
healthy but we will be able to enjoy
everything else in fairly short order
with more vaccines coming there's more
optimism about a future kind of
normal but not in time for the holiday
weekend we continue to ask people
to stay in their household family unit
as tightly as possible it's been a long
haul we've all got the fatigue
and unfortunately we're not quite there
yet the light is at the end of the
tunnel
but the risk is so high especially with
the numbers climbing exponentially
outdoor space the scientific director of
ontario's covet 19 advisory table says
a year into this it's important people
try and enjoy themselves
but safely and outdoors this is not
about big gatherings it's perhaps about
seeing another family from a distance
with cases rising and variants spreading
bc and saskatchewan have added or
extended restrictions
talk is cheap right now action is what
i think we need this epidemiologist is
especially concerned about people
gathering indoors to worship
even if masked and distant you're not
sure exactly
how the ventilation you know is
occurring
and you really just don't want to pick
up
the variant that is circulating in the
community
ontario's premier faces criticism for
not imposing more restrictions faster
stay tuned you'll hear an announcement
tomorrow but i
i am very very concerned to see the
cases go up why
is the premier stringing people along
ottawa is asking the province to move
the city to the gray lockdown level
getting rid of indoor dining
our healthcare system is stretched cases
are rising hospitalizations are
increasing
the testing centers are maxed out we've
never had
ico occupancy as high as it is right now
dr peter uni is ready to release new
modeling thursday
but says at this point we don't need new
numbers to understand the severity of
ontario's problem abigail beeman global
news
ottawa to help put all of this into
context dr ronald st
john joins me he's an expert in public
health and infectious disease control
dr toronto's public health officer said
today that in the race between the
variants and the vaccines the variants
are ahead by a mile what is your
greatest concern right now
yeah my concern about the variants uh
is twofold number one they are more
easily transmissible
and they do appear to be uh to cause a
sl
more more illness and potentially death
than the normal strain
um the other concern is that they uh
tend to be infecting more younger people
i'm told that we're the hospitals are
beginning to see
a younger group of patients i'm talking
between
say 30 and 50. there are calls to change
the vaccination strategy not just to be
age based but to vaccinate
essential workers people who work in
congregate settings a lot of those are
younger people
some provinces are starting to do that
do you think it's a wise idea
well there are two two aspects of the
vaccination one is vaccinating people
who are at high risk
of becoming seriously ill going to the
hospital
occupying our intensive care unit beds
and and having a bad outcome
and those have been the elderly people
but we also have to realize that
younger people are also transmitting the
disease
and to the extent that the vaccine will
stop transmission
uh still still probably true but still
under an investigation
then there's a need to vaccinate the
younger people
so do you think tighter restrictions
need to be put in place now
i do the australians are interesting to
to learn from the city of brisbane with
two and a half
million people had seven cases and they
shut down
ottawa has a million people and we had
over 100 cases we haven't really shut
down
i think there's a lesson there all right
dr ronald st
john in ottawa thank you you're welcome
well it's still just a press release
from the company and it has not been
peer reviewed so there are lots of
caveats at this stage but
pfizer biontech says a small clinical
trial involving just over 2 000 children
has shown its vaccine is safe and
effective in children age 12
to 15. the initial clinical trials on
all the vaccines were done on
adults that is now slowly changing it
doesn't mean covid19 vaccines are being
made available to children yet
but as eric sorenson reports it is a
step down that road
12 to 15 year olds are a small part of
the population but pfizer's breakthrough
may protect a group that vaccine trials
have so far
overlooked children and teens the bodies
of children are different enough from
adults that vaccines often have to be
adjusted but this small trial found at
least for young teens
the vaccine is 100 percent effective it
is very good news
that the pfizer vaccine is effective in
teenagers increasingly we've seen
young and middle-aged adults show up in
the hospital
so let's get our teenagers vaccinated
they can go back to school
engage in their social activities in
canada as in the us the pfizer vaccine
is approved for everyone over age 16.
for 12 to 15 year olds
pfizer is initially seeking emergency
approval in the u.s
and for kids up to age 11 trials are now
underway
protecting young people increases the
prospect for herd immunity
to bring the pandemic under control we
want to get the
people who are at risk for the highest
risk for severe disease vaccinated first
and children will be part of the
equation later on down the line but yes
they are a key element into getting
hurt immunity around the uh the province
and the world okay
two three well then susanna nagy's twin
nine-year-olds are among 48 kids in
another pfizer trial for children as
young as five
this is an opportunity for us to both
potentially get our kids access
but also to contribute to knowledge and
how safe this is for kids
moderna is also conducting trials on
children for now
getting teens vaccinated would not only
allow schools to operate more safely
it could restore teenagers necessary
social development
that's been taken away for the last year
teenagers do get together
socially all the time it's part of their
maturation process
and that'll help us get back to a
semblance of normal
the results are preliminary and have not
been peer reviewed and while approval by
health canada is expected to take a few
months longer
in the u.s it's hoped that young teens
will be vaccinated before the next
school year starts this fall
eric sorensen global news toronto
a group of politicians held a photo op
today to announce they are investing 925
million dollars of taxpayer money in a
plant run by the french pharmaceutical
company
sanofi the idea is to develop domestic
vaccine production here in canada
not for badly needed cobit 19 vaccines
but for flu vaccines
the plant will take years to complete
and as travis danraj explains it does
nothing to help with the health crisis
happening
right now it is a significant booster
shot to canada's ability to tackle what
may come after covet 19
an investment that is set to strengthen
vaccine manufacturing in this country
if there's one lesson learned it is that
we need
to have a strong canadian
biomanufacturing sector
the joint venture between french drug
maker sanofi
and all three levels of government will
help build a nearly 1 billion
production and distribution facility in
ontario
the location and expansion of the
existing site in toronto
will increase influenza vaccine
manufacturing and serve to formulate new
drugs
we are now never going to have to rely
on any country any leader will be
self-sufficient
around 1200 jobs are expected to be
created as a result of the project
in addition sanofi is promising to
inject at least 79 million dollars a
year
more into canadian research and
development of drugs
sanofi can choose to really do this type
of manufacturing anywhere
the fact that they've chosen canada is a
great news story for canadians
good news but canada has struggled to
solidify domestic vaccine production
since the pandemic began in may 2020
canada made a deal with chinese
manufacturer canned sino-biologics
but there were shipping delays and red
tape and clinical trials were cancelled
delays retooling the national research
council's montreal facility
meant canada needed to rely solely on
foreign supply
the new sanofi project is not expected
to be completed
until 2027 still many experts are
optimistic
i think this is big but we may have
further pandemics and one of the things
that we should learn from this one is
how we can be
better prepared sanofi says the new
facility will have the capability of
producing enough flu vaccine doses
for the entire canadian population
within six months of the world health
organization
identifying a pandemic flu strain good
news for the future
as we look forward to getting out of the
pandemic we're currently in
travis danrash global news toronto
breaking down on the witness stand
coming up a bystander who challenged the
police during george floyd's arrest
testifies plus an ex-con is the suspect
in that brutal attack on an
asian-american woman
his gruesome criminal record and ready
to splurge the signs a spending wave
is coming
video of another angle of the arrest of
george floyd was entered into evidence
today at the trial of the officer
accused of killing him
it's police body cam footage and like
all the other video
of those terrible moments it is
difficult to watch
we are not showing all of it i can't
breathe
we've stopped the video at this moment
it goes on to show the officers
struggling to get
floyd out of the vehicle a 61-year-old
man who witnessed it all
from just steps away broke down in court
today after watching that footage
charles mcmillan said he pleaded with
floyd not to struggle and begged
officers to stop pinning floyd to the
ground
my god i asked him to let him up so he
came breathing and
even i said to the office i said
man he said he can't breathe his money
said well if he keep talking he can
breathe
mcmillan describes seeing floyd going in
and out of consciousness and having foam
at his mouth while chauvin pressed his
knee on floyd's neck
chauvin is charged with second and third
degree murder as well as second-degree
manslaughter in floyd's death
he has pleaded not guilty on all counts
new york city police have arrested a
suspect in that vicious attack on an
asian-american woman
a warning video of this attack is also
hard to watch
the man seen in this surveillance video
has been identified as 38-year-old
brandon elliott
police say he has a violent past he was
convicted of stabbing
his mother to death in front of his
five-year-old sister in 2002. police say
he was released on parole
in november of 2019 he is accused of
kicking the 65-year-old filipina woman
to the ground and stomping on her
outside an apartment building
in midtown manhattan police say the
suspect shouted
you don't belong here as he did it he's
facing several hate crime related
charges including
felony assault
roaring 20s in the 21st century still
ahead
what our next reality could look like
statistics canada has released the first
economic numbers for
2021 and so far so good the economy grew
0.7
in january that is the ninth monthly
increase in a row since the gdp took a
plunge
last spring the growth is better than
expected though stats canada says
economic activity is still running about
three percent below
pre-pandemic levels the positive start
to the year
is boosting consumer confidence at least
for those who have
jobs economists at the conference board
of canada are predicting
big things for 2021 and as ann gaviola
explains we could be on the cusp of a
roaring twenties revival
the roaring 20s swept across america
after the deadly 1918 flu pandemic
the similarities between then and now
are striking
technological advances were drastically
changing people's lives
the stock market was soaring and people
were ready to cut loose and spend money
i'm going to try and say yes more
brianna davies has big plans for when
things get back to some semblance of
normal
having so many of the things we like
take for granted
every day gone like the ability to like
go grab a glass of wine with a
with a girlfriend at a new little spot
canadians have been saving like never
before
collectively we've stockpiled more than
200 billion dollars worth
now a lot of that has found its way into
the stock market been used to pay down
debt or to renovate and buy homes
but economists estimate there's more
than 100 billion dollars worth just
waiting to be spent
a big pickup starting in july and
carrying until early 2022.
but supply chain experts say headaches
are in store a flurry of shoppers may
mean shortages
remember what happened with toilet paper
at the onset of the pandemic
but economists warn that if shoppers are
spooked by higher prices
they may rush out to buy things before
prices skyrocket
creating shortages and stoking inflation
so there's a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy that could
occur
if there's an increase in inflation
expectations
this roaring 20s style comeback is
dependent on some moving targets the
pace of the vaccine rollout
the consequences of the more contagious
coronavirus variants
the impact of new financial aid from
ottawa as well as the time it takes for
the ripple effect of the nearly 2
trillion in stimulus from the us
to jolt canada's economy briana's family
is dreaming of the day they can travel
again their bucket list safari vacation
to south africa was cut short by the
pandemic last march
i really rely on travel as a bit of an
escape
to you know hang out with my family the
feeling of looking forward to a trip
and not just the actual trip but
planning the trip and looking forward to
it
gets me through a lot of like stressful
long days
and gaviola global news toronto
u.s president joe biden is ready to
spend money and a lot of it
today he unveiled his plan to help
america build back better
what i'm proposing is a one-time capital
investment of roughly two trillion
dollars in america's
future spread largely over eight years
will generate historic job growth
historic economic growth
help businesses to compete
internationally create more revenue as
well
biden hopes to create millions of jobs
by investing in infrastructure across
the country the projects would be
financed in part by an increase in
corporate taxes
the plan still needs to be passed by
congress
next did an automaker's prank backfire
we've all heard the saying there's no
such thing as bad publicity well
volkswagen definitely got lots of
publicity this week but
lots of people are talking about it for
all the wrong reasons the german company
says what happened this week was an
early april fool's joke and as mike
armstrong explains
not everyone is laughing
[Music]
now there's nothing strange about what
volkswagen was trying to do
another reporter might have said nothing
shocking it's the same thing it's set
out to accomplish with this recent act
i think we're done yet to get the public
to associate vw
with electric vehicles on our way to
carbon neutral mobility for all now it's
one thing to do this
it's another to do what the company did
tuesday
it pretended to accidentally leak a name
change with this twitter video
becoming volt's wagon that's volts as in
electricity
well if journalists were fooled and many
were there were
reasons volkswagen issued a press
release quoting its ceo
and when reporters called to confirm it
all they were reassured
it was true all evs in the u.s will have
volkswagen badging on the rear
wagon the news went around the world on
tv
and online from the usa today to
publications back in volkswagen's home
country germany
well tuesday night a retraction the
company issued a statement explaining it
was all in the spirit of
april fool's day some of the journalists
who covered the story didn't end up
laughing usa today's nathan bowmy
tweeted out a message
dear volkswagen you lied to me you lied
to ap
cnbc reuters and various trade
publications
this was not a joke it was deception
it's wrong it's just simply wrong and
marketing expert robert soroca says vw
broke some rules of advertising but may
have also broken some laws
volkswagen's stock jumped about five
percent when the prank news broke
this is a manipulation of the market and
it's done in a way that's
it's unfair it's it's done on the
premise of a lie
immobility health this supposed prank
comes with volkswagen
still trying to rebuild its brand after
the 2015 emissions scandal the company
had to pay out 45 billion dollars in
fines and settlements
one marketing expert says that may be
the biggest problem with the prank
it's related to the environment the same
issue and got into trouble for
the last time mike armstrong global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
this is international transgender day of
visibility and there are plenty of
canadians to celebrate
here are just a few listed by one of
canada's largest unions
in toronto there's raven wings a black
indigenous artist and activist
monica forrester has spent two decades
fighting for the rights of trans people
and sex workers
manitoba's kale mckenzie is canada's
first transgender judge
and alberta's vivek shreya and yukon's
ivan coyote
are award-winning authors musicians
filmmakers and educators
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you